Some were highly anticipated, some looked
intriguing on the surface but failed to deliver,
and some struggled to even make the public
aware of their existence, but they all have
one thing in common: they tanked badly at
the box office.
Based on a notoriously dangerous real-life
New Jersey theme park, Action Point starred
Johnny Knoxville of Jackass fame as the irresponsible
owner of the most dangerous vacation spot
in America.
Featuring plenty of actual, life-and-limb
threatening stunts from its seasoned performers,
Action Point promised lowbrow belly laughs
along the lines of the Jackass film series.
There was only one problem: the movie's awful.
Fans found the theme park narrative to be
awkwardly grafted onto what could easily have
just been another Jackass movie.
Even though Knoxville practically killed himself
making the movie, the stunts were also seen
as uninspired and the laughs were few and
far between.
Despite the premise and the pedigree to be
a potential horror classic, Winchester was
just a disappointment.
Dame Helen Mirren starred as Sarah Winchester,
heiress to the gun manufacturer's fortune,
who spent decades building strange additions
onto her famous mansion.
The film posited that her bizarre architecture
choices were driven by something decidedly
supernatural
Unfortunately, Winchester relies on cheap
jump scares and questionable plotting in lieu
of anything resembling atmosphere or tension.
"I trust everything has been to your satisfaction
so far?"
"I cannot fault the hospitality."
"it's quite a special house, is it not?"
The John Travolta biopic Gotti got a lot of
press due to its star and subject, infamous
mob boss John Gotti, leading up to its screening
at Cannes.
But its reception at the festival was less
than rapturous, and upon its June release
in the U.S., few critics bothered to review
it.
Literally every single one that did panned
it — leading the film's social media account
to pin its subsequent poor box office showing
on unfair negative reviews.
Literally every aspect of the film's production
was roundly blasted, from its lack of coherent
themes and ham-fisted direction to Travolta's
terrible lead performance.
The movie failed to even make back half of
its paltry $10 million budget, which is a
sure sign of movie failure.
A futuristic sci-fi thriller with a cast most
directors would kill for didn't stop Hotel
Artemis from completely tanking at the box
office.
Part of the problem was that director Drew
Pearce's preference for style over substance
resulted in a great premise falling flat.
Worse, the film's marketing, largely free
of plot or character details, did nothing
to pull audiences in.
Those willing to take the plunge were met
with a convoluted plot laced with laborious,
needlessly expository dialogue.
Despite its modest $15 million budget, Hotel
Artemis didn't even crack half that at the
domestic box office as any good hotel owner
will tell you, you just can't turn a profit
with that kind of vacancy rate.
The Darkest Minds seemed to come with a built-in
audience.
It's an adaptation of the well-received young
adult novel of the same name and features
superpowered characters that could have come
straight from the latest X-Men movie.
Unfortunately, critics took the film to task
for being muddled, confusing and trite and
it whiffed with audiences as well, failing
to even clear $6 million in its opening weekend.
Many critics felt that Minds is guilty of
pandering to its audience, giving them a predictable
story full of tired cliches and obvious plot
twists.
In the case of The Darkest Minds, it seems
like assembling rehashed plot points from
better movies wasn't enough to get audiences
to care.
Many critics thought that Alpha would be a
welcome return to form for Albert Hughes,
who was partly responsible for the classic
hard-boiled crime pictures Menace II Society
and Dead Presidents.
Alpha tells the story of a prehistoric youth
who becomes separated from his hunting group,
and in order to survive, partners up with
a lone wolf abandoned by its pack.
It's a thrilling, gorgeously-shot adventure,
but while the film scored with critics, it
failed to connect with audiences.
With an advertising campaign which seemed
to be aimed more squarely at dog lovers than
fans of epic adventure, Alpha simply didn't
generate the kind of positive word of mouth
that it needed.
It also had the misfortune of squaring off
against Crazy Rich Asians and The Meg, two
films which destroyed at the box office.
Alpha failed to make back its budget domestically,
but it seems destined for a robust second
life on home video.